All from the simple setup that I actually described.
So my wife has been field testing
some of our microscopes
by washing my clothes whenever I forget them
in the dryer.
So it turns out they're waterproof, and --
(Laughter) —
right here is just fluorescent water,
and I don't know if you can actually see this.
This also shows you how the projection scope works.
You get to see the beam the way it's projected and bent.
Can we get the lights back on again?
So I'm quickly going to show you,
since I'm running out of time,
in terms of how much it costs for us to manufacture,
the biggest idea was roll-to-roll manufacturing,
so we built this out of 50 cents of parts and costs.
(Applause)
And what this allows us to do
is to think about a new paradigm in microscopy,
which we call use-and-throw microscopy.
I'm going to give you a quick snapshot
of some of the parts that go in.
Here is a sheet of paper.
This is when we were thinking about the idea.
This is an A4 sheet of paper.
These are the three stages that you actually see.
And the optical components, if you look at the inset up on the right,
we had to figure out a way to manufacture lenses
in paper itself at really high throughputs,
so it uses a process of self-assembly
and surface tension
to build achromatic lenses in the paper itself.
So that's where the lenses go.
There are some light sources.
And essentially, in the end,
all the parts line up because of origami,
because of the fact that origami allows us
micron-scale precision of optical alignment.
So even though this looks like a simple toy,
the aspects of engineering that go in
something like this are fairly sophisticated.
So here is another obvious thing that we would do,
typically, if I was going to show
that these microscopes are robust,
is go to the third floor and drop it from the floor itself.
There it is, and it survives.
So for us, the next step actually
is really finishing our field trials.
We are starting at the end of the summer.
We are at a stage where we'll be making thousands of microscopes.
That would be the first time where we would be
doing field trials with the highest density
of microscopes ever at a given place.
We've started collecting data for malaria,
Chagas disease and giardia from patients themselves.
And I want to leave you with this picture.
I had not anticipated this before,
but a really interesting link
between hands-on science education
and global health.
What are the tools that we're actually providing
the kids who are going to fight
this monster soup for tomorrow?
I would love for them to be able to just print out
a Foldscope and carry them around in their pockets.
Thank you.
(Applause)